if you're a big nerd like me you played
all the Dragon Age games yes well don't
let it get around I have a reputation
and with God knows how many months or
years till Dragon Age 4 comes out I was
excited to hear of a new animated Show
on Netflix set in the world of thedas
Dragon Age Absolution is a six episode
tale set into winter and follows a
ragtag group of mercenaries set on
stealing an ancient artifact known as
the circulum infinitum this magical ring
is so dangerous it's said that it can
restore the Dead with the use of blood
magic an ancient form of magic that is
outlawed by tevinter for it is said that
its Reckless use led to the creation of
the dark spawn and the blights basically
the evil stuff from the games according
to Fairbanks the leader of this Heist
he's been hired by the Inquisition to
acquire this object if you play Dragon
Age Inquisition you'll know that the
Inquisition started as an organization
to protect people from the tyranny of
magic making sure blood elves cultists
and Heretics are kept at Bay basically
the in Inquisition wants to make sure
that the tevinter Imperium isn't abusing
this artifact which of course they are
or at least someone there in particular
is meet Magister rezarin amazine he's
been tasked by the divide the most
powerful figure in tevinter to study the
object but he has a much more personal
reason for taking on this task as a
child he grew up with two elves by the
name of Miriam and neb into winter elves
are slaves yet he treated these two as
if they were his own family and the
three grew up as best friends as rizarin
studied to become a mage he underwent a
trial known as the harrowing the trial
goes horribly wrong with reserin's
mother having to step in and sacrifice
neb in order to save her son seeing that
her brother's endanger Miriam kills
reserin's mother and the trial ends in
two deaths in the aftermath Miriam ran
away and reserin devoted his life to
bring these people back from the dead in
an attempt to right the wrong that he
feels responsible for if he were a
stronger man age none of this would have
happened as we'll see throughout the
series he doesn't blame Miriam for his
mother's death in fact several times
throughout the show he asked her to join
him as he has aspirations on becoming
the Divine himself now Miriam vowed
never to return to tevinter however when
she's confronted by her ex a sorceress
named Hira she changes her mind if
Miriam agrees to help with this task the
two can go off and be together when it's
done nothing like an ultimatum from your
ex The Heist group is composed of Miriam
Hira Roland Fairbanks Lachlan and
quittian they break up into different
groups to cause diversions and trap the
cathedral goers during a service so that
Hira and Fairbanks can NAB the ring but
unbeknownst in the team Fairbanks
backstabs Hera and steals the ring for
himself or at least we think it's a
backstab as later in the series we'll
find that Hira has been the big bad all
along wanting the ring for herself
rather than let Fairbanks escape with
the ring Hira trips the palace's defense
mechanism something that's only supposed
to trigger if there's a 2 and this
defense mechanism spawns all sorts of
demons with the intent of killing anyone
on the premises while attempting to
escape emerium is confronted by reserin
someone she hasn't seen in years she
fights and kills one of his henchmen
only to shock only find out that it's
her brother but how is that possible he
died years ago in his attempt to bring
neb back a reservan instilled a demon
into neb's body think of it as a way to
keep his body fresh while he needed more
time to learn how to bring him back it's
never really explained why you didn't do
this to his mother's body too as you can
imagine this doesn't sit well with
Miriam the gang escapes with a ring but
Miriam is shot with an arrow while
unconscious she is visited by reserin
who uses blood magic to contact her in
her dreams he offers to free hero who
was caught during the attempt in
exchange for the ring and in a gesture
of good faith he heals her wound Miriam
and the team devise a plan to rescue
hero Miriam will offer the ring while
Roland and Lachlan created a version one
which involves quittian unleashing at
Dragon chained Beneath The palace's
Depths here Miriam was once again face
off against her demonic brother killing
him knowing that her real brother has
long since died hero is able to escape
her confinement after the dragon's
Escape causes multiple explosions she
rushes to the safe house to acquire the
ring and Escape but is caught red-handed
we discover the reason Fairbanks
backstabbed her earlier on was that he
knew she was going to steal it but why
would Hira backstab her friends
especially her former lover it stems
back to her youth when her entire family
were killed by venatori basically an
armed Cult of internationalists thus she
has a deep hatred for tevinter and could
theoretically use this ring to bring her
family back or to destroy tevinter
itself for it is said should the
succulum go to the one that seeks it all
of tevinter will burn initially hero had
gone to the Inquisition and asked for
help in this matter but they didn't want
to get involved so she turned to reserin
to make a deal in exchange for the ring
Hira could give him the one thing he
wanted more than anything Miriam herself
for rezaren is so obsessed with making
right the events that went so wrong
those many years ago on the day of his
harrowing only Hira knew where to find
Miriam and had the power to bring her to
him thus the plan was hatched meanwhile
rezaren uses blood magic from nib's dead
body to take control of the Dragon the
team is helpless against the combined
power of the Magister and this Beast so
Miriam has no choice but to let go of
the Ring reserin then combines his nebs
and Miriam's blood with the power of the
Ring to open a portal from Beyond from
the other side emerges neb's Spirit
Miriam apologizes and said that she
tried to save him but he shouldn't come
back it's a bit unclear What neb's
Spirit would have done here should
Roland and Lachlan not have interrupted
the rich with a bomb but my guess is
that neb chose not to come back we see
this brief image of him looking as if
he's returning to the other side and he
doesn't seem that concerned he seems
more at peace Miriam uses the confusion
after the blast to put an end to reserin
but that leaves one major problem that
Dragon who has since regained control of
itself luckily quittian is there and
heals it the Beast rather than fighting
all of them flies off to be free you
know that thing's just gonna ravish the
countryside right with reserin defeated
and the dragon out of the way amiriam
asks Hira to join her in taking the
circulum to the Inquisition she wants
her to turn away from the hate she holds
toward to Winter and choose her over the
ring but before she makes her decision
we see that Hira has put them all under
some kind of spell a spell which knocks
them all unconscious upon awaking they
find the ring has disappeared along with
Hira now hero could have killed them all
in this moment but she chose not to so
it shows she still has some heart in her
Miriam says that without a dragon it
will take hundreds of lives to power the
circulum thus she must destroy it before
Hira takes it to the Crimson night The
Entity she said she'd give it to in
kirkwall and that's exactly where the
show ends as we get this haunting Vista
of the city it seems as though this
Crimson Knight is in control the spirit
of which is encapsulated in red lyrium
red lyrium is said to quote thin the
veil allowing spirits and demons the
ability to interact with the physical
world thus it is very likely that
Crimson Knight is Meredith Stannard
herself Meredith was the main villain
from Dragon Age 2. at the end of the
game she's defeated her lyrium sword
shattering and petrifying her in this
Crystal it's no surprise then that
someone like her would want her hands on
the circulum as it could potentially
bring her back from the dead or at least
out of this Crystal form in the end
credits we can see that actress Jean
Gilpin is credited as Meredith and she's
the same voice actress who voiced the
character in Dragon Age 2. so it looks
like season 2 will focus on Miriam and
the Gang stopping this Crimson night but
what did you think of Dragon Age
Absolution I absolutely want to hear
your thoughts and theories on the show
thanks for watching and be sure to like
And subscribe for more bad takes you can
find me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
good now that the warm fuzzy part of the
day is over with we can get back to the
ritual dismemberments